I mean I I love Godzilla I love being a
part of of this continuity and the
legacy of that character um it doesn't
feel like I'm jump starting anything I
feels like I'm just I'm I'm playing in
this in this you know this River of
Godzilla that hopefully will never end
cuz he's a great
[Music]
character we're in the ' 50s we're in
the remains of a nuclear reactor and
we're with the character of ko and Billy
and Lee um and they are exploring
looking for some evidence related to
monster activity they are going to a
place that is full of
radiation and they are surprised to
discover that when they get to the upper
Center of this place which is sort of
based like on Chernobyl that in fact
there is no radiation there at
all you're already under 3 minutes so
get to work it's a great experience I
mean they're both amazing actors and I'm
a huge Kurt Russell fan from way back
and you know almost you know equal Kurt
Russell and Godzilla from when I was
young you know and so the chance to work
with him was incredible Wyatt's a
brilliant actor and the idea that they
would come together and create this
character was really special you know
and they they they loved that it wasn't
a father and son you know they've been
offered that before they left the idea
that this could be a a joint project and
they are very different actors you know
and I I remember specifically in this
sequence we're talking about at the end
of episode one that Wyatt was playing
with a lot of like what would Kurt do in
this moment you know what's the little
bit of snake pisin I can add to this
like what are these moments and and and
Kurt's at the monitor watching Going H I
like what Wyatt's doing here like how
can I bring a little bit of that and
that approach and how he approaches
things to what I'm going to do and so
it's a beautiful give and take and uh
and I think very special that they met
in the middle and made this this
character that neither one of them
probably would have played that way if
they had just done it
separately there seems to be multiple
sets of
appendages definitely in siik toy
oh it's
stunning we had some extraordinary sets
that our production designer Caroline
henia created for us uh of pretty epic
scale uh a large uh section of the uh
interior sort of reactor was built a
multi-level Set uh and then we built a
large chunk of the bottom floor of the
reactor set which allowed us to to uh
not need much virtual uh set extension
work I mean we did extend in the
distance but we had a lot of things in
the foreground and the midr that were
real and then we had an incredible
special effects team that rigged all of
this uh scenery to shake and move and do
the things that it needed to do which
was wonderful to capture on camera but
also was great for the actors because it
gave them uh the the feeling of being
there and that the floor was falling out
beneath them so like a roller coaster
they were actually on a ride in a way we
had large
glowing eggs there that were not what
you finally see in the finished version
but they were there to create light and
to be able to be something to interact
with um and uh and allowed us to frame
shots and for the actors to understand
uh where they would be so we had a lot
that was real um and then that helped to
make what was not real that much more
believable when they powered up the real
actor must have drawn them towards a
surface to
feed within the body of the show at
large we knew that we wanted to use
pre-existing monsters in key places and
we also wanted to create our own we love
the existing Kaiju out there especially
Godzilla of course I'm a longtime fan
but also the joy of being a part of the
monsterverse is adding some members of
the family so we looked at a lot of
different real world refer reference I
think when you're cre creating a monster
one of the first things you usually do
is look for the weirdest creepiest
things that exist in the natural world
and then you kind of smash them together
and and say is that freaky how does that
work should I put does that work in the
monsterverse um and we knew also about
scale you know part of what is essential
to this sequence is that it's not
Godzilla that you're not meeting the
Queen alien you're actually meeting a
bunch of face huggers in a way right so
we wanted the the idea of the dread and
the horror um to be akin to being buried
alive in a sense you know so what's
happening to KO is she's being
overwhelmed one small creepy thing by
another I think that's part of what
makes it different from a classic
monsterverse scene where you're dealing
with something on a very large scale
this horror is small scale which is
sometimes
worse holy
oh my God we got to
go uh okay forget the timeline we got to
go one more minute no we got to go
now the action sequences in this episode
and in the episodes to come are unique
in that they are so much a part of the
emotional human
storytelling and so it's not human human
drama scene spectacle fight scene human
drama scene like they are all
intertwined that what is happening in
this
reactor is so crucial to everything that
happens in our show emotionally between
these characters and also in terms of
major plot points it has huge
ramifications the show is all about
Legacy and and all about the legacy of
these Monsters the legacy of this
institution this this group monarch but
also the legacy of of of trauma and and
sort of human betrayal and and love and
you know all of the Great Stuff the
messy emotions that that are so great to
watch out get out of there guys come on
get back
here oh my
God oh my God go go go the biggest trick
of all when you do these sequences is to
help the actors and the the camera
operators and the cinematographer and
the production everyone understand what
eventually is going to be there and so
that process begins with me
storyboarding and I storyboarded the
sequence with Jeremy simser is a
storyboard artist I've used on almost
everything I've done over the last
decade it's brilliant and he and I work
together on it for a while then it
becomes this elaborate animation like
previs which where you basically can
create those stor boards in in in real
moving shots and see how it works and
you can change your lens and you can
kind of combine shots and add things and
it's a brilliant storytelling tool but
then we fine-tune that to the point that
I can show that to my actors and to
everybody working on the project and
they can all say oh okay I see and and
it allows them and their imaginations to
be on fire and they can imagine the
glowing you know plastic ball there is
going to be this egg and it's going to
be different and they know that the
tennis ball on a stick that's chasing
them uh is actually this millipede
creature that's going to you know be
terrifying and and all of that's helpful
for for everything it informs how we
light it how we shoot it the size of the
creature we know what it's going to be
and so we built little foam versions of
the millipede so we knew like how big
they would be um and then yes there's me
on the on the microphone you know
yelling out and and trying to help
create you know the drama of the moment
and you know look over here and this is
happening and you know and I had a
wonderful first ad named Jim brebner who
did a great Godzilla noise and he um is
all over the dailies uh you know from
the show Making monster noises
throughout he was wonderful but it's all
necessary because you know you're just
playing in a sandbox trying to create um
things that aren't there until they can
be there by the wonderful visual effects
artists who do
miracles
no no keep
going what makes the show so special and
what works on television in a way that's
different in film is you can still have
scale and spectacle and terrifying
sequences with millipede creatures um
but you're you're invested in these
characters and you're invested in coming
back week to week to see what happens to
them to root for them um to love them to
hate them to be angry and disappointed
in them and all that stuff um and I
think that's what's what's unique is to
sort of see the monsters from the human
point of
view they're
coming